here in an umbrella thorn tree in
Tanzania Africa some fissures lovebirds
are looking for a nice hollow in which
to nest and raise their young the love
bird is a small stout member of the
parrot family they're like humans in
that location is a very important factor
in finding a home and sometimes you find
just the right spot only to discover
somebody else got there first unlike
humans love birds who have found the
perfect tree hollow can be evicted
merely because another bird like this
vanderdecken hornbill besides it might
want to get hooked the hornbill pokes
around a bit
but there's no prey here and this
wouldn't make a suitable hornbill home
so the resident love bird moves back in
it's getting to be the time for the love
bird to make love and to make eggs first
she feathers her nest with some nice
cushy Franz
and she and her mate for life pledged
their union via kissing to seal the deal
the male passes edibles to his beloved /
lovebirds it doesn't get any better than
this